we're going to begin in Washington with
a landmark victory for President Biden
on a bill to tackle climate change and
raise taxes on big corporations in a
strict party-line vote just yesterday
Senate Democrats Advanced those pivotal
parts of Mr Biden's agenda the Democrats
say the bill will cut inflation make
unprecedented investments in clean
energy and reduce the price of
prescription drugs Republicans see it
differently they say the bill will hurt
the economy our team is covering all the
angles including the possible impact of
the upcoming elections I see you there
at O'Keefe but first we're going to go
to Capitol Hill where Nicole Killian has
details of the bill Nicole we're
starting with you good morning hey good
morning to you Gail this legislation has
been more than a year in the making and
while it has been substantially scaled
back Democrats viewed as a big win for
the president and the party
the Senate being equally divided the
vice president votes in the affirmative
and the bill as amended is passed
claws erupted on the senate floor after
vice president Kamala Harris delivered
the tie-breaking vote to pass Democrats
signature economic health and climate
agenda it's been a long tough and
Winding Road
at last we've arrived and we are elated
called the inflation reduction act it is
the largest Federal investment to
address climate change with 369 billion
dollars for clean energy programs
including tax credits for individuals
who make their homes more energy
efficient or buy electric vehicles as
well as the manufacturers who build them
it allows Medicare to negotiate lower
prescription drug prices and caps drug
costs for seniors at two thousand
dollars a year the Congressional budget
office says the 430 billion dollar
package is expected to cut the deficit
by 300 billion dollars it will be paid
in part through a 15 percent minimum tax
on corporations an increased IRS
enforcement Republicans who opposed the
measure had Choice words the Bill's
title shows you what it is it's an
inflation increase act this is going to
continue to drive us into a further a
bigger recession than we are it is a
terrible idea idea Republicans were
successful in blocking a 35 cap on
insulin prices for most Americans that
provision needed 60 votes and only seven
Republicans joined the 50 Democrats in
favor of it it was one of dozens of
amendments that were voted on during a
marathon weekend session that stretched
into the early morning hours Sunday it's
4 50 a.m but the strict Party Line
action finally passed is there objection
and while Democrats acknowledge only
some of the Bill's Provisions would be
felt immediately they emphasized the
significant long-term benefits the world
will be a better place for my
grandchildren because of what we did
today
the Senate is now out on recess for the
rest of this month the house will come
back from its break to vote on the bill
Friday Tony
to understand the Senate would need a
rest very long weekend Nicole thank you
very much